welcome to this video playing a
five-minute game against what does this
name hey dirty sexy money okay yo max
lladro this is the name y'all don't know
let's see you never played them before
inter Russian flag yeah weird line with
a six this is Sir yeah it's a some
getting to some this is a really strange
form of the Banco wear black has played
a six for no particular reason let's see
just developing normally trying to not
fall too far behind on the clock ok what
does flex I dia I don't really know II 6
doesn't look like that
yeah he's playing quickly that much is
certainly the case okay let's see I
don't know g5 really okay well what this
what is the point of the move even don't
really know okay i'm preparing e5 here
let's see i should i go each form yeah
well you five
yeah I wonder be three maybe let's let's
play this let's play this really in a
Nesta teaching fashion we should be 292
and just trying to long-term exploit
this somewhat strange setup on the Kings
side what is he doing here f5
nor may be at five but it looks it looks
really strange okay
my ticket Bishop takes Bishop d3 is
going to take on 83 m Wow
and of course i'd like to exchange the
dark squared bishop this would be very
nice maybe just do that you can play
there for now okay it's no use I'm not
I'm not guessing any office move so I
just go ahead hit play and play whatever
comes to mind guys I'm sorry but this is
this this looks really strange and at
least they're my I'm okay so if i take
now take me seven this is isn't this
just good he's seven what is he doing
look f72 protected yeah maybe it it's
not not a direct win nigera maybe yeah
keep it play it a bit bit simpler
Kim I came so let's see
I can just I can just just take it as
well I mean Queen takes bishop have one
or where's that tick
it takes with the night actually this
this could be a be more more testing and
then just drop it back but okay I can
get cooking age 29 f4 and Bishop
everyone so check
right i want to go to the light square
queen a 5k cannot go to age five that's
very useful
okay rook rook on the file would be
would be excellent obviously but I don't
see how to get it down maybe I can get
the night 25 but also is a quite nice
rook e8 no letter cover that
time morning young became the issue with
the end game is the time but it's
probably still the best way to go
yeah I don't know Quincy for can you do
that I can just take these six-hour
leave
yeah probably i just take these six I
don't see em don't see anything better
judge 6 is hanging as well
check check okay 53 seconds it should
should really be enough it does not
really have lack resign you just not
really have a move I mean if you move
the rook somewhere I have Queen g7 yeah
I really didn't get any of his moves I
mean sometimes you just have that or
when people just think on completely on
completely different terms it just felt
very weird to me all of it I mean why I
play g5 at this position I don't I don't
really understand it ok I'll plate plate
solid move mostly here here there was he
five of course which is also i am very
tempting maybe this is just good i mean
what's blacks movie m I'm opening up the
position I've got everything nicely
placed something like that is probably a
disaster yeah a computer is giving it as
a winner or any like is just falling
apart I mean the pieces are misplaced
and the g5 is it's just yeah I don't
know what to call it I try to play it
them in a more positional manner your
night FYI also also surprised me thought
you would take on your phone but okay
yeah Tiago caref 7 I mean it does not
look great in my from my personal taste
but it's probably a playable move but
this is just giving away please now
Quincy to serve the computer suggestion
this even stronger with Queen h7 a
threat okay that's actually very strong
but hard to do it hard to do for a human
Quincy tool king king here where you
need to do something about Queen age 7
and then it just wants to play this move
intending to win like that really
completely crushing yeah okay but i can
i can just take it and it's generally
just a piece for for no particular
compensation only need to be be cautious
in the limited time but when I got the
e-file it really should the check should
be enough check check young he he just
has no no way to 22 even know threaten
something so here he resigned here yeah
I don't know sometimes I don't don't get
what people are doing maybe that this is
not too bad i mean if you look at the
computers courses it's it's pretty it
says it's pretty ok for black which i
found find really astonishing but ok
maybe it is and i'm just too
conservative as a player alright i hope
you've enjoyed the game thanks for
watching